foreign
Kathy is in North Carolina hi Kathy
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello thank you Dave for taking my call
my pleasure to get to talk to you yes
and Ken I think that's who you said Ken
yes it's me I'm here Kathy today for you
what's going on
okay so my husband and I retired we're
age 65 and 68. you know we live in a
mortgage-free home that's valued at just
under 500 000 and we're debt free
our yearly income is about a hundred
thousand with retirement social security
Social Security
um pension and we have a seventeen
hundred dollar a month rental property
that
nuts style that is included in the
hundred thousand your phone broke up
wait a minute stop stop stop your phone
broke up you have a seventeen hundred
dollar a month rental property it's paid
for too
yes okay good now you're not gonna hear
you again and he has like oh good he has
about 500 000 in third savings that
invested conservatively and his pension
and our social security that's what
makes up the hundred thousand
okay great so
um we live in North Carolina just off a
very popular place called Topsail Island
and people flock here throughout most of
the year
and I've been wondering if it would be
smart to invest in an Airbnb rental and
the one I'm looking at is about 280.
[Music]
and you're going to take out enough of
his Thrift Savings to buy it
no no we'll we'll
um we'll borrow against our house
no you won't
um
no no equity line or anything like that
would be smart you have a very good life
don't go screw that up with an Airbnb
no I knew you were going to say this
ah there it is
let's see if you want to buy an Airbnb
if you want to buy a rental for an
Airbnb take enough out of his Thrift to
do it pay cash for it
would okay how long have you had this
other room
oh goodness gracious we've had did about
20 years
okay can you tell me some tenant horror
stories
you know what we have been so blessed
I've only had one of those okay good out
of all these years keep in mind when you
have an Airbnb you have a new tenant
every four days
yes yes yes
we're talking hassle Factor right we're
talking hassle Factor we're talking risk
factor uh damage uh police being called
uh neighbors griping at you uh all kinds
of stuff that you hadn't even thought
about and we're talking about you're
gonna make a whole lot more money than
you would have just rented that house
but you are getting ready to start a new
small business
that's what renting it renting an Airbnb
is
yeah I understand that yeah and so this
is not like I'm going to just go to the
mailbox and collect a bunch of checks
because Airbnb is a big deal now it's
not it's it's a lot of work
and they're going to tear up your
property and you're gonna put it back
and then they're gonna pay for it and
then you're gonna you're gonna be it's
it's a lot of work it's like it's very
similar to run the hotel
glad for when I tell him
well I I wouldn't I wouldn't do it good
idea yeah if I were in your shoes you
sound like you have a very
simple fun clean life that's very secure
I wouldn't put this beehive in the
middle of it if it was me uh but uh if
you want to go make some money you can
make some money with this but you know
that you're dealing with Hassle and the
only way you want to do it is to pay
cash just something to share with Kathy
and other people that may be getting bit
by the Airbnb bug and you think it's a
sure thing it might be late to the party
yeah you are because we're seeing some
new rev uh some new Revenue data here
all the rooms which uh kind of checks
listings and revenue uh we've seen
significant drops this year compared to
2022 places like Austin uh Sevierville
Tennessee which is to our East uh you're
seeing 47 drops San Antonio Texas 43
drop Nashville 39 drop Denver 38 New
Orleans Seattle Washington there's more
and more cities here and so the point is
there's a glut right now of people who
got into these as Investments much like
you're thinking about Kathy Nashville's
down Nashville's down 30. bachelorette
party yeah keep it going Phoenix
Arizona's down because people don't want
to burst into flames apparently uh
Austin Texas one of the hottest cities
in the flame have you heard about the
Chamber of Commerce well I mean I'm
telling you it's so hot out there right
now people are reading about this but
anyway here's the point you're talking
about major markets throughout the
country where there is more Supply than
there's demanding you can get caught
really quickly and there there's
starting to be a backlash both
politically like people are calling
zoning on it and they're saying some
some cities have passed it's just
illegal period uh and so I'm not sure
that's constitutional but a lot of
zoning stuff's questionable so they pull
off all kinds of crap in the name of
protecting other people but it's called
civilization I think but um but they uh
they regulate our butts off but the uh
uh uh yeah so it's you know
um the bottom line is is the Airbnb
market is soft
and there's a lot more work involved and
a lot more risk involved than people uh
ascribe to it if you properly address
the market and say given that it's soft
the article Ken's reading given the uh
high level of work and Hassle and the
risk of damage
and the risk of the whole thing and pay
cash for it if you Embrace every bit of
that and still want to do it I'm on your
team go do it
because you'll make a lot more money
I'll give you another one okay if you
want to make more money on residential
real estate buy cheap houses in bad ends
of town low income rentals give a much
higher Roi rate of return rent to Value
than high income rentals do in the rich
into town Rich into town you don't
really make that much money on a rental
doesn't do as good but guess what you've
got a higher hassle Factor right you're
dealing with people tearing up stuff
you're dealing with them running drugs
or prostitution out of your house or
running you're dealing with all this
other crap potentially I used to have a
whole bunch of those properties that's
all I know but I mean I had one house
that I paid eleven thousand dollars for
now this was a long time ago right but I
paid eleven thousand dollars for it and
the rent I got on it per month was
fifteen hundred wow now you can't touch
that right but I'm telling you man I had
to collect my rent on the doorstep every
Friday afternoon or they would snort it
or drink it over the weekend you know I
mean it was like so it's a different
you're just dealing with a different
thing so if you want to engage in hassle
to make more money you can engage in
hassle to make more money and that's
Airbnb right yeah uh but but if you
don't if you want something has a she's
gonna her life is so dialed in yes so
sweet yeah everything's sitting there
paid for and she's collecting this rent
and had very little hassle for so for 20
years only one bad story